[موسيقى]
واقع صعب يقود الكثير منهم الى استخدامه
هويات مزيفه للحصول على عمل النظام وهو
امر اصبح شائعا ففي معظم الحالات يستعير
مهاجرون من دون اوراق معلومات واسماء
معارفهم الذين يتمتعون بوضع قانونيتمكن من
العمل
فرنسا
[موسيقى]
انت ليست تخبري في كتير
كتير كتير
مهاجرا من دون وثائق فقد سجل جميعهم عبر
موقع الشركه حسابات باستخدامه هويات مزيفه
ليتمكن من العمل لكن المؤسسه طردتهم هذا
العام بحجه انها اكتشفت وضعهم غير النظامي
بعد حوالي ثلاثه اعوام من العمل معها خلال
الرائحه كورونا وعلى اثر القرار يتظاهر
المئات منهم اسبوعيا في باريس للمطالبه
بتسويه اوضاعهم
نحن في وضع غير النظامي
نحن مجبرون على الخضوع لتلك الشروط لانه
ليس لدينا خيار ليس امامنا سوا هذا العمل
واذا لم نفعل ذلك كيف سنعيش كيف سندفع
ايجار السكن
العامل بدون اوراق له حقوق الا يخاف
يستطيع ان يذهب حتى الى المحاكم الفرنسيه
للدفاع عن حقوقه اييي اذا رب العمل
يعني طرده
اذا ذهب الى المحكمه
اللي هي محاكم خاصه بحقد العمل ما بين
العامل ورب العمل
يستطيع اذا اثبته انه كان يعمل وترضه لرب
العمل ان ياخذ سته اشهر
تعويض لانه طرد
ويستطيع ان يجبر رب العمل في المحكمه ان
يعيد همم اعمال له عقد ويدفع له كل
الضرائب يعني مو لانه ما معنى اوراق يعني
ليس لنا حقوق